freshly minted US Open champ he's Gary
woodland and he joins us on the program
Gary good morning congratulations how
does it feel good morning that sounds
pretty good I like that title the
freshly minted US Open champ that sounds
pretty good if I would have told you at
age 18 you're either gonna play in the
NBA or you're gonna be a professional
golfer you're gonna be on the PGA Tour
which one would you thought would have
been more likely
I thought the golf would have been more
likely what I wanted
when did you realize the NBA wasn't
happening
my first game in college I was playing
the University of Washington we were
playing at University of Kansas I
realized really quickly I was matched up
against Kirk Hinrich I found out my
first college basketball game that I
needed to find something else to do
because this wasn't going to work out
who would you say that you your game
resembled who plays in the NBA well I
was I would say I mean I want to say
Steph Curry but I does just cuz I wanted
to shoot it all the time I couldn't
handle like him I wasn't as quick as he
was but myself I had the ultimate green
light well I'm looking at I'm looking at
some of the highlights here you hit a
jumper against Kansas idea it was 1 for
7 and then and it looked like you took
tried to take a charge I think they
called a block on you yeah horrible you
just get home or call to get all the
calls at home I got home but how
important was did you think you were
gonna play at Kansas growing up that was
a dream you know growing up in Kansas
basketball kayuu basketballs everything
so growing up I we had season tickets
like went to the games always dreamed of
being there never dreamed about playing
against them but I always dreamed of
playing for K you and now I still go
back I I get back as many times as I can
a huge fan of them as now but it was a
it was an honor to play Helen Fieldhouse
I just wished I was playing for the
other team I can't imagine how nervous
you'd be you're I think you were a
Division two basketball team and you go
in to play against Kansas
and you know Kansas I think Roy Williams
was the coach then I mean there was they
were great they were number one in the
country then that was the year that they
ended up losing to Syracuse in the final
we were actually number two in Division
two so we thought we were pretty hot
stuff but we we realized quickly we end
up losing by 30 that it was a difficult
with a different level Paulie did they
cover the spread in that game ompletely
covered by like six points okay yeah so
you covered the spread there Gary when
did it kind of sink in that you know the
magnitude of winning the US Open at
Pebble Beach yeah I don't know if it
truly has when I woke up the next
morning the trophy was next to bad I
realized it was really wasn't really it
wasn't just a dream but it hasn't really
thinking yet but it's uh it's starting
to it's starting to kind of come full
circle celebration I know your parents
were there obviously that was emotional
your wife couldn't be there but you know
hell yeah we went straight to once we
got done in media we went over there to
the you know the famous tapper in there
at pebble there were jordan Spieth
Justin Thomas there were some other guys
there that we had some we had some good
times there kind of put a little vodka
in the company and a little bit wait
everybody did everybody gets a drink out
of the US Open it's like the Stanley Cup
everyone got to drink out of it yeah you
know there's some superstitions in there
so just Nolan
you know he hasn't won and he wouldn't
touch it but speech speech protect he's
he's been there he's won it before so he
he knew what he was doing and I'm
watching you know as you win and they
show your parents off 18 and you know
mom's trying to hold it in and and so
his dad but you know given everything
that your dad's been through health-wise
how did you keep it or at least try to
keep it together walking off that green
yeah it was hard it was it was I was
looking for him there was obviously a
lot of a lot of people standing there
but you know my dad had a heart attack
my rookie year while I was playing at
Pebble Beach so for me to come back you
know a little almost over ten years
later and to win at Pebble Beach my
first major and have him there on
Father's Day I mean it's you can't make
that up and then Father's Day - what a
great Father's Day gift but you could
have won by more so you don't put
more pressure on dad's heart okay the
one question that my guys wanted me to
ask who benches more you or kept good
I'd say he benches more I hit it farther
and he does so it depends on what we're
looking for
how important is that does anybody hit
it further than you
the Cameron champ kid the young kid
don't know I'm getting older I'm up here
now it's not for Nate but when I came
out nobody did but now I'm I've been out
here almost 11 years so but it's so what
are you 35 35 yeah do you consider
yourself old at 35 on tour or I start
hanging out with these younger guys that
I field I walk in the locker room and
you know I've been like I said I've been
I was my 11th year those guys that you
know we're still in diapers when I
started coming out here so it's uh it's
impressive the games in a good spot a
lot of young guys but it definitely feel
like a veteran out there now is it just
a it is golf like baseball I mean it
just you just hit it as far as you can
and or I mean I know you got to be able
to be good around the Greens have touch
and all those things but is it a is it a
power man's game no it is because I
think even if even if you you have
length you know a short golf course
you're still hitting shorter clubs and
you know if I don't have to hit driver
I'm hitting iron on short golf course
where guys do have the shorter hitters
have to hit driver so I think it's an
end things always going to be an
advantage in the letter that the golf
courses are long or short your favorite
shot during those four rounds was what
my favorite one was the last one because
it was over with the one on 17 was
special you know off the green they're
chipping because there was a lot that
could have gone wrong with that that one
and then the other ones those the second
shot on 14 sticks out with out of bounds
right
I know left wasn't good I only had a one
shot lead that really kind of gave me a
little cushion and separated me a little
bit from Brooks what is the the role of
your caddie let's say those fine you
know the back nine on Sunday does it
change then what his role was other
rounds yeah it does I mean he he really
was he was in control he was calm which
it was helped me
Comus well he'd been in the situation
before he was on the bag when my career
when the Masters so he'd been in a major
championship you know Mike was one of
the top players in the world there for a
long time so he's been in that situation
he gave me the confidence there I was I
was actually considering you know laying
up there on 14 and he's the one that
talked me into being aggressive playing
to win and that's really what not only
gave me confidence on that shot but gave
me confidence the last couple holes the
finish and you were a little
demonstrative there gave us a little
tiger fist pump there at you know when
you want it is that out of character
Hawk came out that's definitely a most I
ever never do on a golf course it I I
demand what I didn't know what to do
anymore there was no more shots left I
got more nervous doing all the media
stuff afterwards and I ever was on the
golf course but it all came out there on
18 so what happens now there's life
change when you got you got babies on
the way and what August yeah the lights
gonna change from from that standpoint I
got identical twin girls coming my son
turns two this week
you know I have three kids under under
the oh my god at home so life's gonna be
a little different there but some golf I
still got a long ways to go I still got
a lot to do a lot to prove but it's
definitely going to change at home with
a lot of Rugrats I need to I need to
make more birdies
can you change diapers I have probably
now I've not even we're close to what my
wife does but I would have changed a
diaper if that counts
I think your wife needs a caddy I can't
imagine all the motion you had to feel
there Gary and you're right you let it
out but I just can't imagine you know as
I said with your father you lost one of
your babies you know two years ago and
here you are on Father's Day I mean it's
it's commendable that you just be kept
it together I have no idea what was
going on inside of you because it's you
know in the exterior you're like huh he
seems like he's programmed to do this
yeah I keep it bottled in pretty good it
like I said it came out a little bit
there on 18 but it puts life in
perspective really quick everything
we've dealt with all the golf course but
it all leads to the moment that we were
able to see Ron there on Sunday good
stuff hey
rats Gary hope there's many more for you
and more importantly good luck in a
couple of months here thanks brother
good talking to you thank you Gary
that's a Gary woodland us opened chimp
that's fun for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]